so this is 2 point hospital this is the
game that is about hospitals so we're
gonna get into this and we're gonna make
a hospital and we're not gonna die a
horrible terrible death is where people
go to get healthy and once they get
healthy they pay me money that's how it
works when people go get healthy they
pay me money I get my knee money and
he'll make a censor okay here we go I
can't hear a damn thing
whoa that's that who does it hurt I
can't I can't hear anything what
what is that I can't hear anything yeah
whatever I can't hear anything if
they're supposed to be any sound in this
this is just a bunch of crap this is a
bunch of crap this is what you would
call crap I'm Albert crank
I got no voice get the freak out of here
alright whatever okay I'm sure the
opening was great I don't give a
what my friends are doing you think I
give a about my friends
go away friends alright whatever hog
sport you can hear it now oh good for
you so can i you're not special you're
not special at all I can hear it too and
that's all that matters are you ready to
start building your first off
off I know how to off you you
piece of you Albert crank
I know I'm aware I'm aware baby blue
items ok reception whatever off I
want people to go in the back
all right here we go easy easy okay
people are gonna have to go all the way
here's reception all right so people got
to make the long journey all right want
a system where we go Blake punya no
Sally mal for Wendy Bajor you got it all
right Wendy all right listen when do you
piece of where are you where are
you I'm here when do you know look at me
Wendy Wendy look at me
where do you look at me damn it Wendy
Wendy damn it look at me you look at me
when I'm talking to you
there you go Andy you look at me I run
building I don't care what are you
talking about all right Wendy now you
stand over here in the corner in the
naughty corner and you listen when I
tell you this is so loud why is this
music so loud stop stop I stop I'm
trying to mouse that stop doing here
robas gp okay she's never leaving so we
don't need her door I would like him to
be able to walk right from the office
into here and then walk out window never
mind
okay I may ignore that why wouldn't I
want a window here why wouldn't I want a
window there what do you mean it doesn't
look into the hospital it's in the
hospital
what are you gonna wait what are you
talking about where else would you want
a window what people get naked in this
why would you why would you do that that
doesn't make any sense this is so stupid
what all right fine I guess here's the
peeping window where everybody can see
in that makes sense
office desk yeah okay Thailand Cabo okay
been extinct oh okay
plant okay where's the music news no of
to point County Ricky you listening to
us from the newly opened hospital just
turn up that volume because nothing
drowns out the sound of sick people like
the voice of a world-class DJ who the
are you 42 hours of music from the
background enjoy okay shut up and go
away and Whitney what are you doing
Wendy what are you what are you doing
Wendy honey what the is wrong with
you wait and now everything's in the
goddamn middle of the office no that's
stupid
Wendy god damn it what happened to your
desk did you eat it he's stupid okay
whatever I guess we don't need it all
right dr. Chuck Boff you got it all
right Chuck what are we doing it's open
for business we don't even have a
reception desk
goddamn you ruined my day oh you piece
of oh you stupid desk I move this
room and it move there and now you've
got a window all right so you got that
off with that yes we're done there
we go
stupid piece of crap okay I'm gonna make
a reception right there when you get
back to your desk right now we got a
customer on the way customer oh yeah so
what do we do what do we do in this game
what are we supposed to do are we
supposed to make people better now I'm
sick my bladder exploded I can't believe
it I'll go to this room now let's be
Chuck come here to examine your bits I'm
gonna pop into my office here all right
pop on with this oh wait no oh I thought
that's not the way I put up the desk all
right whatever
don't matter Wow is that it only the
pharmacy oh
get patient ooh wait you way right there
lady you wait right there
pharmacy huh let's see good good
this is where Moses gonna build like a
CVS in this thing all right so that's
the pharmacy there's the door drug mixer
oh yeah give me the drug mixer all right
filing cabinet very important been
equally as important extinguisher maseeh
that seemed about right to myself is
that gonna happen the whole goddamn game
to five if I have to endure that
I am going to stab somebody
okay we need to hire a nurse Marcus
spatula you got it BLAP
all right nurses in the pharmacy are we
actually doing anything here are we
actually making anything happen in that
pharmacy that might be a little small
maybe a little bigger
was cliff wait hey good idea for it you
have like false false paths stuff like
that people think they're gonna be going
to the pharmacy in reality they just go
to a dead end that's what I wanted my
pharmacy yeah yeah you think you're
gonna get out alive nah no way I know
how my pharmacy is just cavernous just
absolutely cactus there we go where's
the where's the entrance I don't know
who knows who knows where it might be I
don't know I think that's good enough
all right pharmacy pretty good they're
gonna die they're not gonna die it's not
like they came in here on an ambulance
they're gonna be fine
probably anyway they're probably gonna
be totally fine and why aren't you
moving faster we obviously need more
drug mixers where are the drug mixers
leaflet stand snack machine okay drink
machine this is where you make the big
bucks this is really where you make the
big bucks oh yeah nice sitter's oh yeah
I don't feel like that should be
something too proud of and you should be
a lot less peppy than you're steppin
it'll attract more yeah you got cured
good job janitors oh hell yeah
Rotex butter
get in here Tex
Jane grot yep all right here we go
Rose digestive sure thing nurse we're
gonna get elect some bauble items for
the how do you get specific rooms for
the items
ah items here we go more oh I didn't
nevermind okay well I got that underway
it's important to keep your staff and
patients happy to ensure a hospital run
smoothly
it needs more plants I don't think I can
actually put any more plants in this I
have no idea what I'm doing
plants
can make it like a haze and Lyga hedge
maze kind of thing going on here
conditions at the voting Hill Hospital
are getting worse every day
apparently patients are just as likely
to die from sinkholes and crumbling
ceilings as any diseases at least
that'll keep the huge day okay all right
thank you build a staff room
I'd have space for a staff room how am I
gonna build a staff room then size three
by two
oh my god oh good god oh my god I don't
know what's she doing hey do you have
something in your hands are you all
right can I help you what is your deal
what are you doing thumbing up
everything what's wrong with you
okay so I need to get rid of these
things or I'm gonna make a room I'm like
a staff room the Lapp easy peasy I know
where to make a break room and lap and
if you guys could wait a second before
you're being about it couch
already got that refrigerator oh no is
this up this is some kind of a locker
situation there we go block the windows
with the lockers yeah we didn't need
anything else anyway I understand plant
plant that's entertaining for a break
room fire extraord no can't do dart
board okay good enough I did it okay
toilet Oh God okay there's one in there
store here's one pooper I can't even fit
one pooper in there what are we talking
about can't fit one pooper are you
kidding me
what is garbage okay fine then this goes
here fill one pooper in here what are
you kidding me I can't fit one pooper
whatever okay I need to get rid of this
thing this go away this go away god damn
it not even room for one pooper just let
me build a pooper this year one pooper
please
one pooper one Cinco are you okay it's
got a toilet it's that's all it needs
you don't need to wash your hands why
would you need to wash your hands you
don't done it's got a poopy right there
[Music]
first again no my mistake anyway keep
those fingers green
okay whatever okay man I don't even
understand you
okay the pooper is open where poop town
USA what are you guys confused or
something what the hell are you confused
about I don't understand what you're
confused about new illnesses general de
god I'm just trying to build my hospital
why do you keep adding new elements to
this I just want to build a nice
hospital I don't have a good time I want
to get duh whatever cure to patients I
did that I did that
general Diagnostics all right minimum
room 3 by 3 which space do I need that's
gonna do it and I'll do it that there
get slapped on the old table there let's
get two tables so you know couples
couples Diagnostics I can't put two
tables you then why did I need a
three by three there's a lot of empty
space what a do I need to put in
there I guess I'll put a reception desk
in here put a pooper in here where's my
pooper
okay I put it over in the now what if
they got what if they got horrible
pooping disease and they gotta explode
the poop out of their poop hole I don't
even understand put a plant in there
you're right
and by you're right I mean shut up there
we go
okay all good in this neighborhood fast
speed can I go faster and whatever
that's fast speed really that's fast
speed whatever
ward unlocked what does that mean what I
mean a ward
what's pill GP offices hire two doctors
well I can hire two doctors easy why do
I need to build another office why can't
they share an office Tex but hurt is
unable to get to where they want to be
you might need to range things to
unblock his route I don't think I need
to do that I don't think I need to do
that at all I think you need to shut up
that's what you need to do you need to
get a whole lot of shut up in your life
all right fine whatever this that helped
all right I had to shrink my pharmacy a
little bit which I hate doing it but I
had to do it apparently I thought I
hired another doctor didn't I hire
another doctor I thought I hired another
doctor Amy tundra fireplace there you go
rooms GP there you go doc and cabinet
and we're good got it nailed it can it's
a little wrong but that's okay okay
doing good how big is the pharmacy not
big enough but I don't have enough space
for it so God do what you got to do you
know we've cured ten patients in total
Wow
whoa golly gee any more janitor to save
the plants are they dying no I guess I
do need more janitors you're right when
you write you write when you write you
write and you write you write you write
what is the Q about well I was trying a
bit I was I was trying to make more
won't let me make another I can't make
another I want to make another one but
it won't let me make another one even I
know the queues long I'm trying to well
let me know I'll just hire more nurses I
guess maybe that'll help does that help
I can't make any more I want to make
more why does it not why can't I I want
to make more why can't I not you need a
ward oh I don't want a ward I'll be this
award
Oh Deluxe clinic oh whatever God why do
I need to build so much crap four by
three I have a room for that oh god damn
it I gotta get rid of my maze I'm not
gonna get rid of my maze I don't care
who you are I'm not getting rid of my
maze
not getting rid of my maze there we go
okay now the ward is gonna be back here
done there we go I don't know what this
is all about but they're that privacy
pooper I guess super pooper is this a
pooper might be a pooper
OOP Abed poop bat poop poop bed whoa bad
done Ward's done remove this there and
then I have enough
it said my level increased but it
sounded like a bad thing why did it
sound like a bad thing I got to build a
deluxe clinic here for some reason don't
know why but here we go
Deluxe clinic BLAP here we go get a door
and get out whatever this is oh well
that's a thing all right whatever got
that I don't know what that's all about
but that looks violent and I kind of
like it because of that how do you need
should I put like two beds in here go on
the pooping room oh oh oh no oh god no
oh god no okay all right guys fine
I probably should have put two pooping
beds in here really wasn't smart about
my leg yeah I'm on don't want to poopers
there we go and we're done right what
the hell there we're done okay now we
got to pooping beds we need another
doctor okay we need a doctor and a
beeves
there go Beavs ewwww all right Beavis
he's there you didn't have plants you're
right when you write you write and you
is right was that one gonna die well
who sucks for you
did you just go in the corner to die and
you're back up Oh
they just kill them they just kill that
man you're gonna die now I know you're
gonna die I'm very aware that you are
about to die
yep treatment failed and you're dead
well I wonder why they freaking ripped
your head off
is this okay is this fine is this fine
is this is this just fine are we just
gonna are we just letting this slide on
this one do I okay all right well then
that's nice boy are you sniffing that
plant smooth snog your nuts no Wow you
are sad okay your three patients of
lightheadedness it'll happen maybe the
light bulb is lightheaded No
is it is it really Wow are you sure
about that you think wait hang on maybe
you're not saying that if they got light
bulb on head that light headedness no
that went over my head hahahaha
because I know get that thank you for
point out to me that is very good of you
thank you hard for your help to me that
I understand mine and brain no get my
brain never get it would never get you
know you know me and brain bad me and
brain you wouldn't bring good that's how
you brain and I thank dear hospital
administrator one-star hospital
congratulations your hospital had been
awarded a one-star rating that's out of
a possible three by the two-point Health
Ministry I have retrieved your file from
my bin to celebrate continue to develop
your enterprise for further esteem and
train kits
I got kadosh I unlocked lower bollocks I
didn't know they could go any lower than
what they were fragrantly your
fragrantly yours that's funny that's
funny all right let's get out of here
this place
and if you happen to be in lower
bullocks this morning watch out for the
gathering of druids down the Broadband's
rang in a total coincidence the town
will also pay host to a psychology
convention today should all work out
nicely
what the hell what the were you
talking about why were you so depressed
the hell was that alright let's go to
lower ballsack psychiatry room that
seems nice
okay why would I want to go through the
trouble of building this all again I had
a perfect place and now you're saying
that I got to do it all over again for
some reason well Lutie duty you you
be I don't understand what I need to do
here can we just be purely psychiatry or
do we have to have like a variety of
stuff why can't I just do one thing why
can't I specialize in just one thing why
do I have to be a hospital that does
everything that's a whole lot dumb I
don't want to do that right here I go
anyway
alright Pharmacy time oh god I'm gonna
make it a nightmare if it totals up to
the area that 3x3 would be then it
should be fine right what a load of
bollocks am i right okay got that I know
it needs a nurse shut up this guy no too
expensive this guy alright he's there
we need general diagnosis that's fine
him three by three my god what is the
point you're right there and there okay
good
Karam ward or whatever that means let me
block this doorway apparently not
[Laughter]
well fine then that's gotta be an
exit there that uh ah blammo abalam Oh a
blammo abalam Oh nurse station right
there and a screen right perfect right
by the window so everybody can get a
good view about a ward okay what do you
have oh God
mocks star that's stupid
shut up all right psychiatry face away
from me if you can I don't want to look
at you while you're sping stupid all
right
higher we need a doctor okay dr.
Duckworth hey you seem all right now you
you seem fine
okay what else we need we need a staff
room all right staff room we'll be right
there
okay that's the staff room couch done
all they need is a couch apparently
staff room easy
he's a PC okay toilet drug mixer to mix
out who you say I don't demand me a drug
mixer - all right where is the bathroom
right here turlet sink you don't need a
sink I suspected that you did not and
you do not know washing our hands here
click the drug mixer then the star well
that doesn't seem right yeah whatever
shut up screw you do I need a janitor or
something
Simon mackerel not too expensive all
right we got that okay we're good right
go fast mode great I'm a very I'm a very
good hospital ER I'm like I'm like the
best hospitalized ER in the world plant
is what I need you're right when you're
right you're right
and you was right plant plant when plant
plant oh come on man
dude what the hell stupid a-hole okay
are we good what else do we possibly
need in pans lab what the what is the
pans lab oh god damn it
okay a pans lab sure whatever they're
all my plans what is that what is this
okay I don't know what that is but I
love it it's gonna be horrible whatever
it is plant land plant or what else we
deluxe clinic there we go good enough
and pretty good what a nice Hospital
I've got here man that's real nice why
do I need nurses 20 nurses bad nurses
too sweet
okay whatever oh well I need another one
why do I need another one all right
Lester okay there we go I think we're
good Louie NYE and another doctor or
something probably another doctor too
expensive okay goody goody goody good I
think we're good to go
right okay whatever they're doing
they're doing whatever they're doing own
two buildings wait what does that mean
own two buildings why would I need
another building why would I want
another building I don't want to own
another building that seems oh I don't
tear down this lovely playground or this
patch of dirt do I take over the patch
of dirt this patch of dirt or the
playground well goodbye kiss
Sira but Dad I like swinging on the
swings can we go on the seesaw Oh No
Zara's on Brock no playgrounds for any
children
cuz this guy's gonna have the common
courtesy to die outside of my hospital
no he's gonna go somewhere in the
hospital yep right there by the toilets
yeah no one goes ever anywhere near
those so why not maybe this guy needs to
hurry the hell up hey review there you
go
nice race for you buddy you better work
faster though because I hate you
better than the first what are you
talking about better than the first the
pharmacy isn't even girthy enough the
pharmacy is not nearly girthy enough I
don't even know what the hell is going
on with this pharmacy it's pathetic who
says I have too many nurses and also how
dare they smooth us numb
there's Norv I see you over there
go back for seconds one more oh maybe I
shouldn't though you've no but I've got
a patient now okay I have no idea how
this is gonna work but uh okay Wow
that's pretty stupid highest priced
janitor this guy's gonna be a nightmare
nightmare of clean lack of girth is a
major problem for pharmacies I'm aware
of this I know this why don't you uh why
don't you step into my office really
frightening dimly-lit bleh wait no not
this this isn't what I wanted damn it
god damn it I wanted a GPS office
that's what I had here we go is what I
wanted why don't you excuse me I need to
go get your file that's nice I need to
hire a new doctor apparently all right
so who's the cheapest all right Bella
goop you go Bella goop
Oh next this is shout at the top of the
lungs
I'm practically dying well need help
real bad
really weeds out the fakers you know if
they can't make the walk to the chair
then they actually do need some help can
I tear is there in another playground I
can tear down that's what I'm really
looking forward to no plants you're
right there we go all done why do we
need another doctor what do we need
other doctor what happened to the doctor
I had thought I had a doctor whatever
hey I think my hospitals failing
pandemic patients there is a plant
there's a plant this is a lovely plant
here
Janek it was play where we need this
please go 90 days without a death uh
yeah that's that's gonna be a hard one I
don't know if we can do that
staff request request denied you know
what red team meeting everyone gather
like look listen I know you guys don't
want death for at least three months but
we just can't have it it's not in the
budget we can't make it work hey
sometimes we all gotta pull up
what is this all right okay here we
go
open the burp award Wow
oh my god I'm ready I'm ready
oh oh oh that's not us
I got an expensive janitor now come on
I've got a great janitor I've got an
incredible janitor this is
oh come on this is a load of crap better
I'm a great employer there we go that's
what I thought
lower ball sack hell yeah hell yeah I
know desk no desk baby oh that one guy
just had to die outside the bathroom god
damn it
okay bungle Meditec got no desk yeah I
doubt that
all right most prestigious okay never
mind then how about Patients Choice
Award you know my patients they love me
such a good hospital right we're loved
by the people yeah yeah I'll take it
don't take it I'll take it yeah Oh
they'd like some place to sit would they
well they can't have it we just don't
have the room
I spilled some put some more plants
celebrate squeeze one in here yeah we
can you know we can play this nice
plants Hospital the place is goddamn
nice there we go there we go that's
looking good poster okay making so much
money
all right cool okay goodbye warm
greeting to you all this fine morning
especially those of you in fluttering
we're renovations have been completed on
the bridge that leads to the town's
ancient castle officials say people
crossing over will no longer need to
wear parachutes and lifejackets just
won't be the same I hate you radio man
what's all this tutorial how do
I get to the real stuff all right I'm
gonna build build this one so good
I'm gonna build a hospital better than
you guys have ever seen I'm gonna build
the bestest bestest hospital in the
history of hospitals ooh mine is gonna
be I'm gonna tear down apartment
buildings make the best goddamn Hospital
you have ever seen just wait just you
wait I'm gonna catch him right
at the entrance I want that booed ambush
him with like yeah hello oh yeah just
like smash him in there okay all right
and then as soon as they go here you
know what they're gonna be hit with two
luscious General Practitioners as his
offices they're almost stanky with how
lush they are nice conveniently placed
filing cabinet I like it a nice bin for
puking in when you get bad news about
your death I love it
this one how do I copy can I copy here
we go easy peasy but I'm gonna move this
over here and conveniently place and by
the door
all right just that easy
I'm gonna make the best ever
it's gonna be the best everyone's gonna
be like oh it's gonna be good okay just
you watch this just you watch everybody
shut up
I want thigh Oh everyone's like oh I'm
Marcus big my can't do nothing as I know
you won't you have no idea you have no
idea this isn't even my final form as
they say on the Internet's
let's go that's what they say oh yeah
now that is what I call nice all right
okay everybody shut up everybody shut up
yeah you know you know I had to do it to
him you know I had to do it to him you
know that I had to do that to them hang
on oh it's we're just getting stanky in
here we are only now just entering stank
zone turlet turlet sink the ship make
the best Hospital everyone was
all like no there's no way you can't do
it marks just an idiot shows who the
idiot is and it's you make the best
Hospital you've ever seen I'll
get ready for this
it has only just begun you thought that
you thought that the slaughtering of how
awesome my hospital is was done it is
not even close to remarkably done I've
got this on lockdown general diagnosis
oh you know you know we got some general
diagnosis reserved rooms you know what
else they need plans whoa whoa getting
good in here hang on everybody shut up
okay all right okay okay yeah okay
okay John's Oh got it nailed it okay
done okay everybody hold on it's gonna
be the best Hospital you've ever
seen in your life
Deluxe staff room deluxe well I'm
talking legit I'm talking too legit to
quit the most legit Aspray chram you've
ever seen in your life
lockers out of the wazoo there we go
okay we got drinks machine we got not
drinks machine we've got a bin we got a
plant
we got poster now that is that's legit
I'm even gonna unlock a television yeah
oh yeah and a private television for
this guy oh yeah no it's good that was
good okay what else do we need now I
need the specialty stuff we need
psychiatry which is its own beast
entirely super calm and peaceful area
like real legit calmness going on here
there's a lot of relaxation happening
there's a lot of chilling out you don't
need nothing in here there's a trash can
for when you got to throw up and you got
to feel safe with all the light head
posters really really just
around you just just surrounding you
that's all it is that's all we really
needed that's good okay all right
everybody shut up so we only need one
more left which is the pans lab like
Pan's Labyrinth hang on we're not done
yet you may think that we're done we're
not done oh we are not done and with
that my friends that's what I call a
good Hospital put fire extinguishers
around here way let's just make sure
make sure we're safe and open for
bidness we need to hire people into
closed for bidness get some cheap-ass
janitors in here BAM plenty of Doc's you
nurses BAM dunzo ones oh here we go I
got this on lock baby oh now that is
what I call a good Hospital
about it guys right give it up for me
cuz of how great I am of how good this
hospital is everybody gets a clap train
going everyone just keep it going never
stop because you know that I'm the best
and everybody can only understand that I
am the goodest so thank you for blessing
your eyeballs with the beauty of this
hospital clown clinic the hell what wait
what wait a minute hang on why do I need
a clown clinic where do you train them
wait wait where do you train them I
don't have enough room I can't oh god
damn it I made oh all right there goes
the symmetry everybody all right there
we go done got it nailed it okay now we
got training room baby okay all right
let's put somebody in start training
course for clown nass motivation that's
what they need to start training
trainers guest trainer there we go now
you need motivation you all need
motivation all right here we go we need
a psychiatrist I'm always getting quite
low not sure we can afford to bills do
you think we need a loan can I get a
loan bad face no know what that means
all right whatever I got it
we're good to go oh oh well we're
not good to go
maybe we should take out a loan how do
we do that alone I like it
okay take got it clown clinic required
well you know what god damn it okay send
them home we don't have a clown Lynn go
away or whatever these guys have
motivation right good clown clinic
unlock well I just sent somebody home
but that's okay
oh no good they're gonna send clowns
after me aren't they well god damn it
okay well what we're gonna do we're
gonna do is again we're gonna get rid of
this we'll sell it I'll make a clown
clinic cuz that's how we roll clown
clinic for by forth and OH
I just sold I just sold my general
Diagnostics why do you have to be a dick
why do you gotta why do you have to be a
goddamn dick why do you got to do that
to me any for I wouldn't make the
breakroom so goddamn big it's our
playground I can bulldoze 40 K 30 Cades
this house and no playgrounds all right
we're buying this one we're gonna take
another loan loan me up baby loan loan
me but build the Clown Wing Wah boom all
right there's gonna be a star to the
clown wing this is we're going to build
slowly I'm not gonna build all
symmetrical style Oh what is
ridiculousness what kind of game if I
walked into what is this why it's just
for goddamn dick ulis now isn't it that
is regard to him dick ulis kind of like
it though was ridiculous but yeah that's
all right there we go all right go for
it yeah I see we needed a new nurse
we're making a profit so that's good
even with our loans
yeah it's gum I've got a gum problem all
right so what am I do I think I need to
hire two assistants because this one's
getting tired I so I'm yawning and
sleeping on the job so it's good no III
really do I have a gun problem I'll like
chew one piece of gum for about a minute
or less and I'll be like okay all the
flavors gone then I just pop it out and
chew another piece of gum and ask Bob
about it he's known it since we first
were roommates back in college I've had
a serious gum problem for as long as I
can remember I did train three staff
what the hell whoa wait what the hell
everybody zoom in on that what the hell
is going on there with their face their
face is real up I don't know
what's happening there but that's that's
wrong okay whatever
all right training is available there
you go start training everything seems
to be running pretty smoothly I still
haven't seen anybody actually get used
to the call the clown thing no I'm not
eating a pretzel you couldn't deal with
that
amy is even more of a saint for
listening to that 24/7
listening to what what did I do be
hilarious is that what I did
oh no such a cry me being so undeniably
funny all the time don't know about you
but I find the real essence stream of
death someone depressing do you think we
could go a few months but I didn't but
no one died no one no one died why would
anybody that impress the VIP with a nice
Hospital I've got a nice hospital right
here I need a psychiatrist where's my
psychiatrist Sammy Pound Sammy pound
baby
mayor Tabitha wind is coming in
pharmacy emergency okay we've got plenty
of pharmacy you do it we've got plenty
of pharmacy we got more than enough
pharmacy oh your hearts broken oh well
whatever you have the same gum problem
yeah I don't know why I can't do gum for
like long-term and just I can't chew gum
if it doesn't have flavor it's super
weird I feel like this is a traffic
problem right here so I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna I'm gonna sell this bench I'll
pick up this one I'm rotated and do like
this that better I'm probably better you
guys need to hurry the hell up got a few
minutes
too many people waiting okay promote ah
that's funny hey we got a star okay fine
we're gonna keep going though okay did I
do it I think I impressed the mayor help
with the and that flew up my nose
to hell and if we buy my nose and then I
sniffed real hard and was right right up
there he'll oh my god yeah plenty of
protein I guess I think I'm done I'm
bored this games kind of fun kind of
dumb I think we can call there yeah I
think it's good enough hope they all die
you know in fact in fact you know what
let's go
and there we go nice and we're all good
there we go okay I have fun everybody
else okay see you all right goodbye
[Music]